i'm kyra in tally bar from the Finnish
unit of the language service and today
there is a summit going on. We are
translating the conclusions and other
documents produced by the European
Council. It's maybe the most motivating
part of our translation work, because we
are responsible for very important
political documents. We have to be really
at our best. Even normally we have quite
tight deadlines, but this is even tighter.
Every language has a little island like
this and translators and assistants work
together in it. We work on the screen or
on the paper, depends on the case. It's
really a team work and we discuss
formulations, words, terms, all kinds of
things. We do research. It's really about
knowing and sensing your own language,
and it's especially in important
political documents as we translate here
the details have to be exactly right
because words are also political. I very
much like translation work because it's
really striving for perfection and
knowing at the same time that perfection
in translation is impossible but it's
nice to see how far you can get